There were all kinds of pagan beliefs
being mixed with Christianity that
unfortunately some Protestants still
believe today that are actually not
scriptural at all when you really study
it.
>> I lost my daughter two years ago. She
was born April 4th and she died 10
minutes later. Family members telling
me, "Hey, don't feel sad. She's in the
air with us."
>> Nobody wants to believe all their kids
are going straight to hell.
>> The concept of soul actually comes from
Greek and Roman mythology. You know,
obviously what happened understanding
history is that
>> Have any of you ever lost somebody
really close to you?
>> No.
>> You [music] haven't?
>> I mean, not like an immediate family
member.
>> Really?
>> No.
>> Have you?
>> Wow. Yeah. My grandma [music] from South
Africa.
>> I [music] wasn't. And I'm sad about that
because I my my my mom is from South
Africa. [music] My dad is Dutch but he
moved to South Africa, met my mom, they
lived [music] there and they moved in
Netherlands. I was born eventually I
came here
>> and so I didn't and at the time
the you know computers and internet were
just really becoming a thing. This is
like the what is it when did she pass
away? Early 2000s.
>> Mhm. And [music] so I just didn't really
have an opportunity to connect with her
because you you couldn't call over the
internet like you can now [music] where
you you can't couldn't have long
conversations. If you did it was very
expensive and I was only eight when she
passed away. [music] So I knew my Dutch
grandparents really well and I never
really got to know her. And it's
unfortunate because she was actually you
know she [music] passed away with faith
in Jesus as a Christian.
>> But I have a hope that someday I'll see
her again in heaven. you know that and
I'm looking forward to that when I could
actually get to know my grandma a bit
more. But she passed away of cancer.
[music]
>> Yeah.
>> So
>> I probably should have defined close
because close wouldn't necessarily have
to be a relative,
>> right? That's true.
>> Close could be a friend. But you said
no. But then you like my grandma.
>> That's true. I had a I had a good friend
of [music] mine in in Los Angeles that
um he ended his life and that was a that
was a heavy hit for me. [music] So yeah,
I just haven't thought about that in a
little while. Yeah. Yeah.
>> And I should add I've also my other my
Dutch grandmother passed away. My South
African grandfather passed away. So like
there's multiple grandparent. I have one
grandparent left at this point.
>> Yeah. So
>> So on my end, I guess I would say
cuz I was thinking of it when you when
you phrase it in terms of relatives, I
would say yes. But when you phrase it in
terms of closeness, I would say no.
Even though I lost my dad,
stepdad last [music] year, biological
father year before that, but I never
knew him. So, there was no like really
relationship there. And then other than
that, I would have probably said the
person closest to me was my stepg
grandma.
>> Well, my grandma and my stepg grandma,
but yeah. Was it like I remember when
you told us that your stepdad had passed
away and but you're not close like what
is that like when you come to
realization that this person is dead
>> but you weren't actually close to them
but you were supposed to technically
because he's your stepdad.
>> I mean it's weird for both very weird
for both because they actually died
almost exactly a year apart.
>> Your dad and your stepdad you mean?
>> Yeah. So, the way I remember it is
there's a temptation song that says it
was the 3rd of November
>> that day. I'll always remember that was
the day my daddy died.
>> That's actually the day my biological
father died.
>> Wow.
>> Um, but again, I didn't know him. I only
saw a picture once in my entire life.
>> That was it.
>> Does he look like him?
>> Never talked to him.
>> Do you look like him? I
>> I don't even remember what he looks like
because it was such a surreal moment. It
was just complete blur. And so my b my
stepdad though, yeah, that was
I don't know. I wouldn't say it was hard
to lose him because
he was a hard person to
>> understand.
>> Yeah. I just wonder what it's like when
it's like, you know, that person is gone
and it's like
>> I mean, I didn't cry,
>> right?
>> It didn't like really affect me that
way. It was just like
>> happened.
>> Mhm.
>> Which sounds like really cold and
callous, but when you
>> when you don't have that bond with
somebody, it doesn't affect you the same
way. Anyway, here we are like
monopolizing the conversation and we
have somebody with us and everybody's
like, who is [laughter] that lady and
why is she here?
>> But we should pose a question to you,
Sarah. Have you lost somebody close to
you?
>> I definitely have and I lost my daughter
two years ago and so wow.
>> Yeah. So, this is a very is your
daughter.
>> She was She was born um April 4th and
she died 10 minutes later.
>> Wow.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh wow. Oh wow.
>> Yeah. So it's infant loss.
>> Yeah. So she was born and Yeah.
>> So it's a tough conversation, but
>> there's hope at the end of it.
>> Amen.
>> So
>> I always wonder if that's harder than
>> losing a baby in the womb because you
got to see it and it actually came to
life. Yeah, I thought that as well, but
I feel like a loss is a loss cuz you you
you're expecting to see a baby at the
end of this. And so,
>> yes and no, maybe, but it's it's hard
nonetheless.
>> Right. Right.
>> And you know, there's something super
spiritual about having the ability to
create children,
>> right?
>> Because I I I remember I mean, obviously
I'm not necessarily creating the child.
My wife was the one that was carrying
it, but it was on my mind. I mean, when
I had my children, it was like, what if
they don't survive or what if there's
something wrong? And and I can remember
that was being the first time that I
kind of was confronted with those
thoughts and and you know, just what
what what would happen or what would I
do if if uh one of them, you know,
didn't make it.
>> Yeah.
>> I think about that more now that they're
older. [laughter]
>> I didn't think about it so much then. I
think about it now because my kids are
two of my oldest ones are driving. I
have another one who just got his
permit. So, I think about that all the
time. I'm like, what if it would what it
would be like to lose, you know,
somebody who's in their teenage years,
they're just starting to like blossom.
>> And I think you're right. Any stage,
it's probably difficult. It probably
doesn't matter
>> when.
>> Yeah, it's tough nonetheless. But
>> yeah, God has birthed this story, this
testimony in me, and I believe this is
the moment for it. I actually I was
telling you this earlier that I
visualized this while I was going
through that.
>> Wow.
>> I'm curious. Had you lost any children
before?
>> No, I haven't.
>> Okay.
>> No miscarriages, nothing at all.
>> Had she did was your daughter born with
any
>> medical condition?
>> Yes, she had anesphille.
>> What is that? What is that?
>> Basically half of her brain wasn't
developed.
>> Oh wow.
>> Yeah. And so they told me to, I don't
know if I can use this word, end the
pregnancy at 4 [clears throat] months
when you do the the
>> the ultrasound where you see all the
parts. I forgot what it's called. And
they told me to end. And I said, "No, I
don't believe in ending my child's
life." And I still had hope in
>> in God healing her nonetheless. So
>> So you kind of had a mental preparation
that it wasn't necessarily that was
sprung on you. And
>> so it was like 6 months of like kind of
torture. I didn't tell my children. I
only told close family members. Church
members didn't know until it happened.
So, it was like holding in
>> this secret for 6 months. So, it was
>> it was tough.
>> Wow. I mean, you know, you're you came
in here and you're smiling and you you
have this just like very pleasant
personality that sometimes, you know,
you don't you don't see through into
people's, you know, pain that they may
have. Yeah.
>> And so, you know, you you you uh I'm
sure have a story to tell of what's
coming out of this, but
>> yeah,
>> praise God that you're still smiling.
>> Praise God. Yes. Beauty into ashes.
Ashes. What is Yeah. There you go.
[laughter]
>> Wow.
>> Beauty from the ashes. There you go.
>> And of course, you have other children.
>> Yes.
>> You have more than than me, which is
rare. I don't meet a lot of people who
have more than four. [laughter]
>> How many children do you have?
>> I have five in total now.
>> You go, girl. Yes. So, God blessed me
with a rainbow baby this year. And so, a
rainbow baby is a baby after a loss of a
child. And so, yes, I'm grateful for
that. I have four boys and one girl.
>> The last one is a girl.
>> No,
>> as a boy as well.
>> Is a boy. Yeah.
>> Yeah. I lost a girl.
>> Yeah. So, I have one daughter.
>> You'll have six when you go to heaven.
>> Yes. And that Yes.
>> All right. Well, let's talk about it.
So, have you ever read a story that
helped you understand grief from a
child's perspective?
>> That's interesting. I never have.
>> You never have. Right.
>> So, you're saying you're saying like
like a book or something like that that
that helps the children understand
something tragic that happened. No,
that's really probably
>> understand grief. Interesting. I don't
think I have. I have read a book from a
child. Well, as an
>> happened to a child, but they wrote it
as an adult. Mhm.
>> Um, but it wasn't necessarily dealing
with the grief. It was just kind of
telling about their experience. It was
more or less like a testimony. A child
Called It. You ever heard of that book?
>> Mhm.
>> I think
>> A Child Called It.
>> Yeah. A Child Called It.
>> I think it was written by Dave Melzer.
>> It was the third worst case of child
abuse in California history at the time.
>> Wow.
>> Really intense. I mean, like, could not
put the thing down. Really intense
story. I've certainly heard some crazy
testimonies over my years of working in
ministry of of of abused children and
and man, you just sometimes you just go
like what what some kids are exposed to
is beyond my imagination. So I think
that this is a very needed field.
>> This is interesting.
>> Yeah. So
>> because when I came home, I guess let's
start from the beginning. Um back in
2022, um I became pregnant with my
second daughter. I had three boys at the
time and my daughter was by herself. So,
I was excited we're gonna have another
girl. And then the dreaded day came when
I got the call that they found something
in in um a test we took. And so, it w it
was confirmed later, a couple weeks
later, that
>> she had the anephily and the doctor, he
said, "Hey, try again. End the end the
pregnancy and try again." I'm like,
>> "That was a little kind of
very cold." like
>> a life in me. And so Mhm.
>> And so um I was devastated. And during
this period, this is the most I've heard
like God like he was very he made
himself very evident in this period,
>> right?
>> Um and so when people ask me how did I
do it, I'm like it was nothing but God's
grace that carried me through.
>> And [clears throat] so [gasps]
yes, I kept it in. And then April 4th,
like I stated, exactly what he said, it
happened. Like I said, I had hope that
God would heal her. And I said, "Okay,
Lord, if you heal her, I'm going to go
to every TV station and proclaim that
while God is still in the miracle
working business."
>> But he decided to do another miracle. He
kept me
>> to tell this story. And so, nonetheless,
I praise God and he he reminded me
through his word in Isaiah 35 that, you
know, he will wipe away every tear and I
will see my daughter. And he usually
answers prayers yes, no, and later. Not
now.
>> And so, my prayer was answered and he
said, "Not now. I'm going to heal her
when I come back."
>> Yeah. You know, when that child's handed
back to you.
>> Yes. And we're going to see you get a
chance to raise him. Yeah. And and you
know, God is just like a merciful,
loving God. And so it just seems like,
you know, heaven's going to be this this
crazy place with [laughter]
a lot of children that I'm sure didn't
make it very far in life, you know.
>> Yes. Yes. And I named her Celeste. And
the reason why I named her Celeste, cuz
the next time I will see her is in the
skies.
>> Oh, nice.
>> And so that's what Yeah. Celest like
celestials in the sky. Oh, yeah.
>> So yeah,
>> I imagine that's a great motivator. to
to be in heaven, you know.
>> So, why do you think it's important to
teach biblical hope to children early
on?
>> I think his life is full of probably
disappointments and and [clears throat]
things that go wrong.
>> I mean, we live in a pretty messed up
like situation. I'm sure when we get to
heaven, we're going to be like, what did
we just survive?
>> Like, probably.
>> Yeah. This is this is a hard, you know,
school of hard knocks. So to teach the
children how to process those
>> needed is very much needed and I
appreciate this ministry because you
guys are exposing the darkness in media
and you know they're teaching our
children and it's important for that
that we are instilling God's word in
them. And so uh until we meet again
that's the title of the book. Um
>> so you wrote that?
>> Yes.
>> It's a children's book but it's a book
for anyone who's going through grief. I
just wrote it in, you know, a language
that children can understand.
>> And so,
>> you did this because you work with
children
>> and mostly because my children because,
you know, they were in it with me at the
end and they had so many questions like
they didn't understand like in the book
it would talk about us coming from the
hospital
>> and they were like, "Where's the baby?"
And we actually had to bury her as well.
And when my children went to the
cemetery, I believe that was their first
time, they was like,
>> "Yeah,
>> what's going on here?" So that's part of
>> the process that and all those things.
Yeah.
>> I was homeschooling at that time. So
it's not until later that year I lost
her, I started teaching.
>> So it was mostly because of my children.
>> You know, I I think this is also an
awesome opportunity to talk about what
happens when you die. Like I I'm
assuming you're going into that, but
talking about the graveyard. Like
imagine taking your kids to the
graveyard for the first time. Well,
that's an oppos a al awesome opportunity
to talk about
>> there's actually no such thing as like
spirits going around and all these kind
of things, you know.
>> So, [snorts] also within this time
period, if it wasn't the prayers of my
church family, my family members,
>> I would not have made it. Um, I can tell
you a time where I was deep in grief,
like I was grieving before the loss, if
you can imagine, cuz they told me that
would happen. Yes, I had my my hope,
>> but you know, that's still in the back
of your head. And so there there were
times where I would be crying in my
bedroom by by myself and I would get a
text from a [clears throat] a church
member telling me, "Hey, listen to the
song." And the song is ministering to
what I was dealing with at that moment.
>> So I knew God was with me through this
hard time. So um I also decided to do an
intercessory prayer journal because I
also have, you know, you ever ran into
someone and they say, "Hey, I'm going
through this." You say, "I'm going to
pray for you." And then you probably
forget
it. And so I wrote I I made the journal
so I can always write the names of
people because I want to return what
people did for me. And so I I have their
names, the date they gave me their
prayer and hopefully they come back and
tell me, hey, your my prayer was
answered and I put it there and that
builds my faith. And when I look back,
I'm like, wow, look at all these prayers
that God has answered. And so
>> he's checked off quite a few.
>> Yes. Yes. Awesome. That's really
beautiful. We we actually um pray as a
team together every single morning and
we write down in these prayer books. I
think we filled up a couple of them
every single page. And we've been
keeping this kind of going since maybe
2015.
>> And I mean, you can look back over those
pages and you can just see like so many
of them have come to to
>> praise God.
>> We we try to pray for people too when
they send in prayer requests like
through email or on in you know, we
don't read every single comment
unfortunately because there's so many.
But when we do happen to scroll comments
and we see a comment but ask for prayer,
we put it in our uh Slack work chat and
then we pray over those as well.
>> Believe it or not, during that time, I
was watching one of your videos and I
put a comment, I need prayer, and
somebody responded.
>> And so that's awesome. So the community
is beautiful. Praise God. Praise God.
>> And so yeah, that's a part of it all is
that. Okay, let's go into the truth
about death.
>> Let's do it. During this time, the
comments that I would get was very
interesting from family members telling
me, "Hey, um, don't feel sad. She's in
the air with us."
>> I don't think that was comforting. It's
not comforting. I don't know if they
thought that would help me to know that
my baby was not comforting to you
>> because my baby should be here with me
in my arms. I know I have a faith. I
have hope that I will see her in the
future, but it doesn't take away from
the pain, you know, that you're not here
right now. And so it's all these little
moments that, you know, encouraged me to
write this. So
>> yeah, and it's not something you'd
normally talk to children about. I mean,
really, you don't just start out like,
hey, hey kids, you know, about death,
you know, like
>> like, [laughter] you know, maybe they've
heard it or been around like we've been
in church and stuff like that, but but
yeah, I targeted, you know, hey, here's
what happens when you die, right?
>> People probably need to make their
children aware of these things.
>> Yeah. cuz they're seeing all these
ghosts and people in the cartoons
falling and they rise up like they're so
confused. So I had to make sure my
children had this foundation in word in
the word of God.
>> Genesis 3:4 we know the biggest one of
the biggest lies
>> um that we know of in the Bible. You
will not surely die.
>> And we know who from the mouth of who
did that come from?
>> It was the serpent. It was Satan.
>> Yeah. And through the ages we're still
seeing this lie. My daughter's floating
in the sky. So
>> his breath goeth forth. He returneth to
his earth and that very day his thoughts
perish. And so we see the
>> the contrast. The enemy said,
>> "Yeah,
>> we won't die."
>> And in Psalm it says that very day your
thoughts perish. You're not floating in
the air. You're not in heaven. So it's
very important that um we seek these
truths in the word. That's actually a
really good verse to to illustrate
because yeah, if you're continuing on,
let's just say you as an adult, you die
and you go to heaven. You know,
>> if your thoughts perish, then what? You
don't you don't remember who you are or
anybody else like that. You know, it's
like there's some some logical things
here that you'd have to say. Yeah. I
think that people have a hard time,
especially if they they've got a a
different view in their church of the um
immortal soul. And we also see in
Ecclesiastes 9:5,
for the living know that they shall die,
but the dead know not
>> anything. That backs up the previous
verse.
>> So in other texts in the Bible, it talks
about how when someone dies, like the
spirit will leave them.
>> But when you really look at some of
those texts, this spirit is used
interchangeably. Um it can also mean
breath.
>> And the the Hebrew word for that is ru.
Mhm.
>> And so really it's basically an
incorrect translation to put spirit
there because it means breath if you and
and you could say well how do you know
if it's breath or spirit? Well, you have
to look at the broader context of the
whole Bible and all the scriptures and
understanding really what you're
explaining now which is state of the
dead and these kind of verses where here
it is used breath then yeah it it it
cannot be that there's like a separate
soul or a separate spirit in there and
and you kind of
>> talked about this as well I think in one
of the first verses where it says that
we are a living soul
>> and I think if different translations
actually translated as you are a living
being and that's correct like you are a
living soul well does it mean that I'm
currently like a floating entity like
going out of the room. No, I'm a human
being, right?
>> Um the the concept of soul actually
comes from Greek and Roman mythology.
>> Wow.
>> And so you know obviously what happened
understanding history is that you know
you have the Christian church that came
about and then that also happened during
the time of the Romans. So then
eventually part of the Christian church,
not everything because the Lord has
always had a a pure Christian church,
right? The pure people of God that that
are faithful to his word, but part of it
started mingling with um Roman paganism
and it became a corrupt kind of
Christianity that was it was not pure.
It was just there to for greed and money
and all these different things. And so
pagan Romanism, right, with the idea of
the soul mixes with Christianity. And
then there were all kinds of pagan
beliefs being mixed with Christianity
that unfortunately some Protestants
still believe today that are actually
not scriptural at all when you really
study it. But out of that eventually
came after a long time came the Roman
Catholic Church. This is not a me
bashing Roman Catholic church. It's just
explaining the history of it.
>> And then that eventually you know what
became the worldwide church for hundreds
of years. So everybody believed and was
a Roman Catholic until the Protestant
Reformation happened. And then some
Protestants started looking back at the
scriptures and realized this is actually
not scriptural
>> and started denying these beliefs about
eternal soul or separate soul. But
that's really it's just like drenched in
in in Protestant Christianity even
because of that history.
>> Right.
>> But if you study it, it's not it's not
accurate.
>> It's not at all.
>> And the Lord God formed man of the dust
of the ground and breathed into his
nostrils the breath of life and man
became a living soul. And if we go back
to Genesis 2:7, it says dust plus God's
breath equal the the living soul.
Exactly.
>> And so,
>> so if and we are made from dust
according to Genesis. So if you take the
dust like us
>> and you remove the breath of life that
God breathed into Adam's nostrils into
humanity,
>> what's left? It's death, right? So it's
the same equation. I I I think that one
of the main reasons about believing like
you immediately go somewhere to heaven
or to hell
>> um is is quite a fearful thought if you
actually think about it. I mean, it's
not a pleasant thought to think if your
child is not in heaven, where else could
they be?
>> And being tortured and, you know, it's
like, did that child choose that life?
And, you know, it's like now you really
complicate this thing and and to me,
>> uh, I think the devil just loves to
throw confusion in there and it and it
creates a fear. But I think that if you
understand it from the biblical
perspective that when you die, you're
sleeping in the dust
>> and waiting for God to make that final
decision, I think is less fearful.
>> I think it's the original sin problem
that Catholicism has because,
>> you know, instantaneously all these
children that are born are sinners.
>> Yeah, that's baptism. They're going to
go straight to hell
>> if they're sinners and they're not
baptized
>> and they're not sprinkled. Yeah.
>> And that's a big marketing problem. You
know, if you're a big machine like that,
>> nobody wants to believe all their kids
are going straight to hell.
>> I think also the idea of having an
eternal soul and [laughter]
I've mentioned this before on this show,
but
>> like in this case, it was your baby that
passed away, right? So for some people
maybe it is comforting to think like my
baby is in heaven with Jesus. Yeah,
>> but you know the Bible allows that if
you are your spouse passes away and you
can remarry and marry a different
spouse, right?
>> So just imagine that your first spouse
that you love very dearly is going to
heaven and he's looking down on you and
>> now you get remarried and now you're
like intimate with your new spouse. Like
does it mean that they look at all those
things or like no that's when they turn
like but that's confusing and there's no
tears. So
>> there's no tears. So now let's say your
um loved one passed away and now um you
get violently attacked in the streets.
Do they watch you go through that that
you know but there's no
>> there's no tears, there's no fear,
there's no pain.
>> So do they then watch you go through
that with like a robotic sense of no
emotion? So it really just gets really
when you think
>> odd like that if you think it through.
>> I think it's it's there's a lot of
confusion because it's highly
speculative. If you look at um accounts
of people who have supposedly died
>> and come back to life,
>> none of them agree.
>> Exactly.
>> Yeah, that's a good point because they
go and it's like in heaven everybody's
young and they'll go and then he
everybody's old and or it's a mixed bag
or it's different descriptions of Jesus
or whatever. There's no consistency in
that at all.
>> Even with the near-death situations,
it's always a different
>> always different. see Jesus or they see
uh whoever they believed culturally.
>> Very true. We actually have a video on
our channel uh where Mikey, a former
host of our show, he talked about the
near-death experiences situation
>> and and just because there's YouTube
channels out there with gobs of, you
know, they've collected all these videos
about near-death experiences and people
seeing Jesus or some people see aliens
or whatever and and he explains it how
from scripture that's not accurate. And
so you might think, well, why are these
people seeing these things? Well, you
know, some sometimes if you're drugged
up and you're laying on a hospital bed,
stuff happens to your brain. Exactly.
That's really what I see it as. Or
>> I I believe that this theology, this
idea isn't biblical. So then it could
even be that the enemy might give you
these thoughts and people might be very
genuine, not like like hammering on the
people who have them,
>> but just saying that there he is called
the deceiver for a reason.
>> Exactly. And to tie into what you said
about the fear, um I believe God is so
merciful. Um before I knew the truth of
the Bible. Yes, I was raised um in the
church all my life, but I didn't know
all the truth until in being an adult.
And so before as a mother, I would have
this fear that if my child dies, I need
to be able to usher them up. You know,
you're you're I'm responsible for them.
So if they die and I'm still here, what
happens? So, it's not until I knew this
truth, I'm like, Lord, you're so
merciful. They're just sleeping and he's
going to wake them up when they when he
comes back. And so, that's comforting to
me. Yeah.
>> There's tons of scriptures that confirm
that thought. I even just recently read
through Acts, I think it's Acts 7 where
Steven gets stoned, Steven the first
martyr,
>> and it says at the end like, you know,
they threw a bunch of rocks at him and
he went to sleep and then you never hear
of him again. I don't think that I would
go to sleep if somebody just stones me,
you know, like I'm sure you're sure that
we know that stoning was a way to to
kill someone, right? So, and then
elsewhere like Lazarus, he Jesus said
Lazarus is dead. Lazarus left. He uses
both scriptures.
>> Lazarus didn't have a whole lot to say
about it either.
>> Exactly. He didn't have this grand story
like, "Oh, I saw all these angels and
stuff." True.
>> Hey, if I was Lazarus and I got sent
back down here, I'd be mad.
>> Like, would [laughter] my Lord go and
hate it? That's a good point. That's a
good point. Imagine when God, you're in
heaven. You're like,
>> you pulled me out when I made it and
then
>> you bet that [laughter] he would be
vocal about
like Jesus, why'd you do that to me?
>> Yeah,
>> that's a good point. I never thought
about that before.
>> In his in in this account, it says Jesus
says, "Our friend Lazarus sleeps, but I
go that I wake I may wake him." And you
know, the disciples, they were like,
"What are you talking about, Lord?" And
so he had to clearly say that he he has
died. He's dead.
>> Lazarus is dead.
>> Yes. And so later on in verse 25, he
says, "I am the resurrection and the
life."
>> Usually people probably think Jesus,
you're kind of like,
>> Yeah.
>> What kind of audacity do you have to say
you are the resurrection? And it's true.
He is life. And wherever he is, you
know, death has no power. And so he had
to clarify that during this account. And
of course, we're still talking about it
thousands of years later. And so,
there's a lot of encouragement in this
this um account. It
>> I think it's just really cool that I
don't have to fear death.
>> That when I die, it's like this and it's
like this and it's like second coming.
>> I missed out on everything in between.
>> That's true.
>> So, I'm I'm actually one of those people
that I like to sleep. [laughter]
I actually love sleep.
>> It's sweet. Every time I climb into bed
at night time, I'm just like,
[clears throat] "Yes, why can't I
[laughter] just go to sleep all the
time?"
>> Funny. I think it's a waste of my time.
I want more time in my day.
>> It's a pleasure to me to go to sleep.
Like, I've never actually had a hard
time falling asleep. Sometimes I do. I
mean, everybody's had these wake sleep
awake awake all night long experiences
and I've had those certainly in my life,
but but I like the just rest, go to
sleep, and then you wake up in the
morning, it's a new day. To me, that's
how I view why he calls it this. It's
not something to be feared,
>> you know. I mean, we I think we fear it
because we don't understand it
>> and or how we're going to go. Exactly.
>> And that's one of the fears as well. And
so, I feel like sleep is like so sweet.
Yes.
>> So, I hope I pray that's what they
experience when their eyes close is just
>> Yeah.
>> and just go.
>> I just think, you know, it's temporary.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, you know, you're going to
sleep, you know, you're going to wake
up.
>> That's amazing. Yeah. And God he also
when the world became sinful this is
also his grace for us to sleep because
if we experience the for eternity sin
like can you imagine the horror
>> yeah what a what a terrible thing like
you know what if you were a child that
you know you had a pretty normal
childhood and you just chose the wrong
things in your adolescence. So, does
that seem logical that God would torture
you for billions and billions and
billions of years
>> because you made, you know, some choices
at this one year, you know, and it's
like I think that there's a lot of
variables there that that just to me
don't seem like a nice
picture of God.
>> Yeah. Eternal fire. No, no, it's not
>> it's not the truth. And then we look at
Martha in the story of Lazarus and she
proclaimed, "Yes, we know that you're
going to raise him up
>> when you return." I don't know if anyone
ever stops to think about what Martha
stated. That's interesting. Yeah. She
proclaimed the gospel, the the truth of
God's word. And um she didn't really
understand that. He said, "I'm going to
wake him up right now. You get a taste
of what's to come."
>> Well, I think it's really neat that that
Jesus wept. I mean, this is where, you
know, the shortest verse in the Bible,
John 11:35, Jesus wept.
>> And just that thought of like he's going
to raise Lazarus, you know what I mean?
And the fact that he felt that human
emotion
>> because he was he was saddened by the
experience that other people were and
you know, he's experiencing those things
as well. So,
>> but it also testifies about Lazarus
because when Jesus says that I'm the
resurrection and the life, um, he that
believes on me, though he die, yet shall
he live.
So what does that say about Lazarus?
>> It says he was someone who believed that
even if he died,
>> he could be raised from the dead.
>> He had a lot of faith.
>> Can you imagine if he did it like
Lazarus?
>> So
>> yeah, it wasn't just a [laughter] a
Jesus making a proclamation for
>> Wow.
>> future peoples. I think it was for him
as well.
>> Mhm.
>> Mhm. [clears throat]
>> That's I never thought of that. We like
the amount of times I read this like h
God's word is amazing. It is. It's so
deep. I mean, you can literally sit
there and read like two, three verses
and just like think on it for hours.
>> My goodness.
>> I love it. Yeah.
>> And so, um, like I said, Jesus calls
death sleep. He has the power to wake us
up.
>> Yeah. It's like you close your eyes
>> and you open your eyes.
>> Yeah.
>> It's like sleep.
>> You only blinking and see the coming.
>> Completely pointless if you're already
awake.
>> You mean like if they're awake in heaven
or
>> Yeah. Yeah. What's the point in waking
somebody up?
>> Yeah. If you go right back
>> Yeah. you you you Well, then what does
it mean to sleep if that's the case? You
know, it's like
>> you're What does it mean to die if
you're not dead?
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's true. Like, how do you
die? I mean,
>> which is [clears throat] goes all the
way back to the tree of knowledge of
good and evil, right?
>> What does it mean to be mortal? Look
that up in the dictionary. Do you know
what it means? Subject to death.
>> Yeah. To cease.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, what is death if you just live?
>> Yeah. Like it doesn't make any sense. I
mean they have the same definition then.
>> And why would Jesus say like I'm going
to give you eternal life, you know, at
my second coming when basically if you
now die to then be in heaven, you
already have eternal life.
>> Yeah. He's bringing the reward. The
reward isn't granted. And yes, there are
people we have examples of Moses in
Elijah, Enoch. So, you know, I can
imagine that God took examples and
representatives just like he raised
people when he raised himself. I think
that's also important too. Jesus when he
took his breath and you know breathed
his last what happened to him? He didn't
[clears throat] just like go somewhere.
It's like he had the power to lay down
his life and he had the power to take it
up again which means he stopped and then
he brought himself back.
>> Take it up again.
>> Yeah. And I think this ties into
something even deeper um with people
taking their lives. Can you imagine?
Okay, you passed away thousands of years
and you're in heaven before me. Like you
get to experience it before me. And so
if you understand that in that way, hey,
what's it to just end it right now and I
can just go experience
>> heaven, right?
>> That's a good point.
>> Yeah.
>> And I've thought about this many times
before like
>> like why if heaven is something you can
go to right now as soon as you die, why
would everybody just take their life?
Why wouldn't you end it for everybody
right now? Like why would Jesus say,
"Well, yes, I'm going to get you to
heaven right now as soon as you die, but
but you're going to have to stay here
and suffer through it and hope that some
like it gets really muddy."
>> Well, yeah. Depending on your paradigm
shift, if you commit suicide, you're
it's a straight ticket to hell.
>> Some people believe that, too, which
that's a whole do that.
>> Yeah. Is there a Bible text that would
give that impression?
>> No. I I I think it's the it depends on
the situ God judges people according to
their hearts and I don't think we can
cast judgement it's it's kind of partly
based on one of the ten commandments
thou shalt not kill thou shalt not
murder taking your own life
>> yes
>> but I I I say that with a caveat of
there are some some situations where
like children have been abused they did
not choose that
>> it set them off on this trajectory of of
a lifestyle that like they probably
would not have chosen there's a a lot of
variables there that you cannot just say
because that happened.
>> We we allow for that in our own judicial
system. You know, even though it's been
heavily abused, there's that temporary
insanity or whatever, you know, that
people have been able to they're not in
their right mind when they God take that
into account, you know, [snorts]
>> I would imagine.
>> Mhm. There's grace
>> thankfully. And like I stated in my
shirt in the back it says um 1
Thessalonians 4:16-17.
For the Lord himself will descend, not
us going on our own. [laughter]
>> He will come down.
>> Yes, he will come down with a shout. And
the dead in Christ will rise first. Then
who are alive and remain shall be caught
up. And so we shall always be with the
Lord.
>> Amen. That's pretty clear. And again
like
>> pretty clear. Is it like like Keith was
saying earlier, you're in heaven and
then you get pulled down all of a
sudden? [laughter]
>> No.
>> Well, implication is if you're if
they're dead in Christ, that means
they're not alive in Christ.
>> I mean, if you're in heaven, wouldn't
you be alive in Christ?
>> Yeah. Cuz some then some people might
say, "Well, I'm dead. My body's dead,
but I have this soul." But then the
Bible's clear that the soul is us as
human beings. You are a living soul.
There's no such thing as a separate
soul.
>> Amen.
>> Yeah.
>> So, our greatest hope is to be reunited
with our loved ones in Christ. So, that
makes the second coming even sweeter.
That those who who have fell asleep in
Christ, that we will be reunited. The
biggest reunion, like the biggest
miracle will be when he raises all the
dead people. And so,
>> that's amazing to know and understand.
>> Yeah. I think that's that's the great
hope that we have in Jesus
>> and the blessed hope. There you go. And
this is an image that encouraged me
during that time. You know, grief never
ends. It you know, you have ways to cope
with it. And so when I looked at this,
this is the second coming and you can
see if you look closely, you'll see an
angel returning a baby to a mother. And
so this is what you know guides my hope
and encourages me to keep on this
journey um to meet my daughter.
>> Yeah.
>> Again,
>> I worked on a project um with a teacher
of mine actually when I went to grade
school and his daughter passed away when
she was 18. She had a brain aneurysm and
um she was like class president and just
like you know very very active in the
church and the school and
>> and I mean when I worked on this project
it had been probably 20 years since this
experience had happened to his daughter
just woke up one morning and she just
you know he didn't get a chance to say
goodbye or anything
>> and he said something to me that really
stuck with me. He said it's always right
under the surface like like that pain
doesn't necessarily go away. Yes,
there's days that you can deal with it
easier, but he said as deep that you
feel the pain, it's like God opens a
door that you can feel the love as well.
>> And I thought that was a profound thing
that he said because you know through
all this pain that we experience here,
>> maybe we are given a a situation that
you you you do hold your other children
more closely or you you know what I
mean? You can experience love in a
different way because you understand
what it means to lose someone. I'm
curious. Did you do any grief
counseling?
>> I did. Um, one of my churches, they um,
one of the churches I I am linked to,
they have this grief ministry. Yeah.
>> And so, it's like a six week, I believe,
um, course that you can take over and
over whenever you feel the need. And so,
that really helped me. It did help.
>> It helped me a lot. I know this same
teacher he's talking about, he um he
talks about how he was told after they
lost their daughter, and I think they
was like 9 days before they were
graduating or something too. So, it was
like real close.
>> But he he said they were both told his
parents, you know, you need to go to
grief counseling. And at the time, he
didn't see the need for it. He thought
it was okay,
>> but he did it. And then he reflects back
because he said he had this moment where
he was walking out into a parking lot.
He couldn't find his car.
>> And it was at that point he just snapped
>> down.
>> Everything just hit him like a ton of
bricks. I mean, it had been like a year
since he lost his daughter. And at that
point, he just lost it.
>> He was triggered.
>> And if he did not have [clears throat]
those tools from that toolbox, he's
like, I wouldn't have been able to cope
>> and deal with the situation. I could see
why he took so long because with me it
took me like probably nine months to to
even entertain going to grief ministry
because like it it's like a band-aid you
keep
>> opening and so I understand it's not
easy.
>> Another reason why I think this is a
very necessary field that you're
embarking upon here is uh that same
teacher he said that pretty much
threearters of every marriage will fail
when something tragic happens like this.
A lot of [clears throat] marriages can't
sustain that. So it's not only
>> you know the children that need to
understand but the parents as well. How
is how has things been with you know
your your family as a whole dealing with
this.
>> Oh and the book touches on that how we
our faith is what kept us connected and
so us attending church regularly. Our
our church family our pastor you know
staying you know
>> in close
communication with us kept us going. And
so we talk about it. We're open um
whenever our children have question,
we're we're open to talk about it and
discuss it. So yeah.
>> And you probably experienced in this
your in your home again, same teacher,
he's he pointed out
>> different people grieve differently.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. And so did you find that was true
in your home with your children, your
husband?
>> Yeah. my children as well. They some
behaviors were developed um during that
time and thankfully their school had the
grief counseling and so they were able
to give them the tools to handle that as
well. So in all facets we saw
>> this affect our family immensely.
>> So if this happens to somebody that's
out here in the audience, what would you
suggest to them to start? Maybe they
don't even know where to start. How
would how would that happen?
>> Okay. And so I, like I said, I have I
have the prayer and intercessory
journal. I also have a regular journal
that I used daily during my grief when
it was fresh. I just put my my thoughts
to to letter on in my notebook. Whatever
I felt that day, it was there. And so
also when God did something for me, I
would go back and read. I'm like, "Okay,
God, he carried me through this time and
I know he'll do it now." So I called it
remember. So journaling. If you don't
know what to do, if you don't want to go
to counseling, guide, like I took my
time to go, start with journaling and
praying. Like the Bible says he's
closest to the brokenhearted. And I
truly felt that during this time, my
Bible and my journal is how I made it
through that dark time.
>> So,
>> you know, you think of of God, it's like
he knows what it's like to lose
children, right? So you're dealing with
someone that you know on a grand scale
has lost a lot of children
billions I'm sure I don't even know how
how long it's taken our world to double
in size right since the 70s I think we
only had four billion in the 70s now we
have like eight nine something like that
so you know you think about if the
world's been around for 6,000 years it's
probably quite a few people and
>> Adam and Eve they have a child that
probably will not be in heaven you know
and it's like here these people are like
working with 100% of their brain.
>> My goodness.
>> With a closest to the perfect model as
as humanity could get.
>> Yeah.
>> And they uh experienced losing a child
as well.
>> And they know that they were actually
the cause of that because they're the
ones who directly allowed sin to enter
this world and then that child did this.
Like dude, I I don't know what I would
do in that situation. So jumping off of
that, do you feel that um you your mind
tends to blame yourself or like how do
you process how
>> from the beginning I I kind of blamed
myself until the doctor he told me this
was like a one in 1,000 chance of
happening to someone? And so God had to
remind me, you know,
>> nothing happens by accident when you're
a believer. And I was told that by my
midwife and other people. Things just
happen. But God, he reminds us nothing
happens. He doesn't waste your tears.
And that's why we're here today that I'm
expressing this testimony that God has
given me. So
>> I I really believe that the idea or the
statement that um
>> if we could see the end from the
beginning, we wouldn't have it any other
way.
>> That's hard to say when you go through
something like this
>> that you'd be like, "Okay, God, I would
agree with you
>> and I would have it the same way." Like
I believe that God is like that. Mhm.
You would never do something against
>> you know what's bad for us.
>> I've heard that with people with Down
syndrome children
>> like this is something that we thought
was going to be this terrible awful
tragedy but it actually enhanced our
life in such a way and like there's just
like you know people that embrace that
and just hey this is this is a matter of
chance or whatever and they move forward
with it that there's actually a blessing
that comes from from having a child like
that. So, um,
>> you know, maybe that's not the right
word to use, blessing, but [laughter]
>> then you deal with it in the a different
way and maybe it brings you closer to
God if you allow it to.
>> Yeah, it does. It does definitely. And I
want to piggyback on something you said
earlier how God has experienced his
children dying. And so when he comes
back, he comes back with a shout, right?
And so you think it's to end our pain.
>> Maybe it's to end his pain. He's been
seeing countless murders and kids being
abused. He's coming back saying, "Okay,
enough. No more. I'm done seeing this."
And so that's another perspective, too.
God's perspective of the pain,
>> grief,
>> even though he knows the end already.
>> Yeah.
>> Now, how do you see moving forward? Do
is this something that you would suggest
if somebody's lost a child to to
periodically or check in or this is a
lifetime of you need to
>> you know continue to to explore um these
topics with a counselor or what do you
what do you suggest? I suggest cuz just
like the grief ministry, they leave it
open. Even if you lost someone 10 years
ago, the doors are always open because
you always need that that pick me up.
And so always stay connected with with
these kind of resources they give you.
Um thankfully the hospital, they offered
um counseling as well, but I preferred
more of a faithfilled um counseling. But
what what whatever you need to do, I I
suggest that you continue to tune up
because it's a lifelong unfortunately.
We're in a sinful world. We're going to
experience pain. Um but what gives me
hope is that we're tasting a a little
glimpse of Jesus suffering and so we
know it's not forever. So
>> Amen. Amen.
>> Mhm.
>> So you've wrote a book.
>> Yes.
>> Where can we find your book?
>> Until we meet again is you can find it
on Amazon. Amazon.
>> I am an indie writer. I looked that up.
I guess someone who self-publishes their
books. And so, yes, you can find that
now on Amazon.
>> Yeah.
>> But like Jesus says, he is the
resurrection and the life. And as you
mentioned, believe on him,
>> he will turn things around. And
>> um just can't wait for that second
coming. It'll be so much sweeter.
>> And you'll be that person that uh that
angel will put that baby in your arms.
Ah, I can't wait. I can't wait. That'll
>> be awesome.
>> Yeah.
>> All glory to God.
>> Amen.
>> Mhm.
[music]